la nouvelle a fait le tour du web en un
clin d'oeil la populaire application
vidéo facetime peut être piraté en
quelques clics pour écouter un
utilisateur sans son consentement fait
un bond qui existerait depuis une mise à
jour qui était fait au moins d'octobre
et donc potentiellement ça ferait trois
mois qu'on serait capable d'exploiter
cette faille là combien de gens l'ont
fait on le sait pas c'est ce déroule
comme suit d'abord une utilisateurs fait
ce thème en contact un autre
puis il ajoute une troisième personne à
la conversation lui même ce qui provoque
un bug qui permet d'écouter la personne
contactée sans qu'elle le sache si la
personne refuse l'appel sa propre caméra
ou piratées mises à jour qui sera fait
mais en même temps à pau ça fait dix
rebelles dont vous n'êtes pas une start
up c'est que ce genre de truc leur vous
auriez dû y penser vous auriez dû faire
les contrôles avant de mettre cette
application là en ligne
un jeune d'à peine 14 ans qui a signalé
le bug découvert par accident en
manipulant son cellulaire
pourtant apple a la réputation d'être
plus sécuritaire que ses concurrents si
au départ hasard ya des gens comme vous
et moi qu'on est capable de trouver des
failles dans des logiciels quand même
très important maintenant que peut faire
un effort pour aller jusqu'à elle s'en
servir contre nous ça c'est la
possibilité et la réalité d'aujourd'hui
une solution possible faire le ménage
dans ses explications
si on utilise mais l'application sur
notre plateforme de la tablette ou le
téléphone d'incendié mille possibilités
de compromission d'information alors
qu'on en a besoin peut-être de 10
rappelons que cette faille de sécurité
arrive un bien mauvais moment pour le
géant à pau qui a subi d'importants
revers en bourse tout récemment ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal